bonsoir est qu'il sera vite vous
retrouver ça vous regarde version d
confiné c'est parti voici le sommaire
c'était une bien belle idée des bras nos
assiettes est bien là fait flop peu de
chômeurs ont finalement prêter main
forte aux agriculteurs à l'heure où
certains rêvent de créer des milliers
des centaines de milliers d'emplois dans
le monde paysan
la réalité est plus cruelle on en
débattra quand un virus à raison de la
surpopulation carcérale grâce aux
mesures contre l'épidémie en prison le
nombre de détenus est inférieur au
nombre de places et c'est historique
comment maintenir cet équilibre après le
col vide on en parlera avec le directeur
de l'administration pénitentiaire ainsi
que maïtena biraben pour la dernière de
des confinés sur lcp enfin le jour
d'après gros plan ce soir sur la
géopolitique de demain etats unis chine
europe quel nouvel ordre mondial après
la pandémie
grands entretiens ce soir signé sylvie
kauffmann voilà donc pour le programme
hashtag sévère ça ça n'a pas changé on y
va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
vous souvenez sans doute de cet appel
appel vibrant signé du ministre de
l'agriculture
moi je veux lancer un grand appel un
grand appel à l'armée des ombres à
l'armée de l'ombre un grand appel aux
femmes et aux hommes qui aujourd'hui ne
travaille pas un grand appel à 2,16 et
ceux qui sont confinés chez eux dans
leur appartement dans leur maison à
celles et ceux qui sont serveur dans un
restaurant hôtesse d'accueil dans un
hôtel à la halle aux coiffeurs de mon
quartier à celles et ceux qui n'ont plus
d'activité et je loi des je le redis
rejoignez la grande armée de
l'agriculture française est bien la
grande armée elle n'aura pas déferlé
dans les champs bonsoir richard ramos
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
député modem du loiret amoureux du monde
agricole même ancien critique
gastronomique vous êtes chevalier
anti-malbouffe on a hâte de vous
entendre sur ce flop de la cueillette
local si j'ose dire vous débattre et ce
soir avec la piquante géraldine woessner
qui fait son grand retour dans ça vous
regarde merci géraldine d'être avec nous
journalistes au point et chroniqueuse
dans cette émission c'est vrai qu'elle
était belle cette idée au départ à aider
les paysans en manque de main d'oeuvre
pendant la crise alors qu'est ce qu'il
s'est passé
bonsoir ces femmes il est où mon
stéphane stéphane blakowski je le vois
la magnifique bibliothèque je ne sais
pas si vous avez là où vous êtes
derrière votre écran mais y en a pas mal
c est un bon signe je dirais si j'ai
bien compris tout de suite
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris stéphane ce soir
alors si j'ai bien compris un myrian en
france ont produit des légumes qui sont
vraiment très bons des screen qui sont
délicieux on a un seul petit problème
c'est que les français n'ont pas le
courage de se baisser pour les cueillir
alors le résultat que ça c'est que
compact la récolte pourrissent dans les
champs et chaque année la france va
faire appel à des travailleurs de
l'étranger mais vu que cette année les
frontières sont fermées avec le virus eh
ben c'est aux angoisses mais comment on
va faire pour que l'on créé nos légumes
pour je dois avouer qu'au départ le
problème paraissait pas insurmontable on
se disait sur les 12 millions de
chômeurs départ de france en chômage
partiel
on va bien trouver 45 mille volontaires
c'est possible quand même eh ben c'est
pas si évident d'accord il ya eu 300
mille candidatures ça c'est vraiment une
bonne nouvelle mais finalement il n'a
simplement 15000 qui ont été retenus
alors faut dire que du point de vue des
agriculteurs le travailleur français
n'est pas du tout à la hauteur du
travailleurs polonais alors je dis pas
ça parce que je m'appelle black ops
sinon je dis ça parce que damien rio
producteurs de fraises en bretagne nous
était que les nouvelles recrues
françaises sont un peu décevantes vous
embauchez 12 personnes ne lundi matin en
fait il y en a que huit à se présenter à
midi on a déjà une de moins
au bout de trois jours il n'en reste que
trois et en fin de semaine voilà il nous
reste qu'une personne et ça c'est
quelque chose qui n'arrive jamais avec
ces polonais ah non pas du tout puisque
elles viennent vraiment motivés alors
attention il faut pas non plus se
flageller seul manque de motivation
n'est pas spécifiquement français en
allemagne c'est exactement pareil sont
disciplinés ils sont courageux ils sont
durs au mal mais les allemands ont quand
même dû faire dire 40000 roumain pour
assurer la cueillette des asperges et
sinon la récolte était situé à la
solution la plus originale elle vient
d'italie l'agriculture italienne a
besoin chaque année pour pareil que la
france récoltait de centaines de
milliers de travailleurs étrangers qui
vivent clandestinement en italie
mais puisqu'ils sont utiles à associer
les italiennes pourquoi ne pas les
régulariser c'est ce qu'a décidé le
gouvernement la ministre de
l'agriculture l'a annoncé comme elle
même a été ouvrier agricole à l'âge de
14 ans elle est un petit peu nous
permets moi par mon histoire personnelle
tournoi un point fondamental
et je me réfère à l'article 118
l'émergence d'un cadre de travail légal
à partir d'aujourd'hui grâce à la
décision de son gouvernement
les invisibles seront moins invisible et
si alors cela dit il ya des nations
parce que dans l'agriculture que où les
étrangers en bas des pardons occupent
des emplois pénibles et mal payées
c'est le plan dans des secteurs
nettoyage le bâtiment la surveillance à
pourquoi ne pas faire comme l'italie si
ces gens sont utiles à la société
pourquoi ne pas les régulariser et en
même temps avec le chômage qui augmente
on se demande si les français vont pas
être obligés d'accepter des emplois
pénibles mal payés et du coup on aura
moins besoin de travailleurs étrangers
merci stéphane ya plein de questions
dans ce billet d'humeur on va on va
commencer par par le début richard à
mousse cette initiative tout le monde à
la louer au départ c'est plutôt un flop
est ce que ça vous surprend non j'ai
forcé ne pas reconnaître l'agriculture
d'abord on a vu dès le début de
l'émission on a vu les asperges il en
reparler moi j'ai ramassé des asperges
dans le val de loire quand j'étais gamin
pour gagner mon argent de poche
l'objet qui les ramassent s'appelle une
gouge si vous la mettez de travers
voudrais pas c'est pas l'aspergent c'est
un métier c'est à dire qu'il faut
arrêter de penser c'est comme si on
pense que serveur c'est juste porter une
assiette sur une table c'est un métier
et donc les gens qui venaient les
marocains qu'ils nettoyaient la ligne
tailler la vigne c'est un métier et donc
au delà du courage au delà de ce mal de
ceux du rau ce dur travail qu'ils sont
c'est un métier de travailler dans
l'agriculture s'improvise pas comme ça
et donc croire que on aller comme ça sur
un coup de baguette magique dire à des
serveurs vous devenez des ouvriers
agricoles
c'était une erreur mais au départ les
des poupées est bonne il ne m'aime
beaucoup de jeunes qui lui pend dans le
confinement voulait être utile celui riz
jeunes au chômage partiel aussi il faut
rappeler quand même le dispositif vous
étiez rémunérées non mais je ne sais
rien de s'improvise si vous voulez dans
l'agriculture
on a besoin de gens qui sont même si on
a l'impression que c'est des métiers pas
qualifiés qui sont qualifiés et puis
après c'est dur c'est à dire que yahia
il ya un travail dans l'agriculture qui
est physique
et quand on n'a pas eu l'habitude de
faire ce travail physique là c'est pas
du jour au lendemain qu'on peut le faire
ce travail là alors oui il faut réguler
il faut régulariser
pardon les travail régulier bien sûr
qu'il est régularisée travailleurs
étrangers sur qui ne demandent pas
nécessaire c'est pas des clandestins qui
travaillent dans leurs champs faut pas
exagérer enfin s'il peut enchaîner alors
il peut y en avoir d'autres 8 rien à
voir mais reste là moi je serai pas tout
aussi négatif que vous parce que alors
c'est vrai que ça fait un flop
sap a fait un flop uniquement à cause de
la pénibilité c'est à dire que sur les
sur les 300 mille candidatures par
exemple les 30000 qui était à paris déjà
ensuite le problème de loger tous ces
gens on est quand même en période de
coronavirus si on peut pas en mettre
plus que dix dents dans des chalets fin
il y avait tout un tas de problèmes
quand même qu'ils soient et 1000
candidatures quinze mille candidats à un
contrat à l'arrivée même recrues même
c'est un peu moins d'ailleurs - ils vont
sais pas d'ailleurs quel type de contrat
mais c'est très peu mais il faut bien
voir c'est pas seulement un problème de
salaires c'est beaucoup ce qu'on a
entendu c'est super mal payés s'est payé
au smic 1 ou 1,2 smic c'est pas plus mal
payés que d'autres emplois saisonniers
que qu'un emploi de serveur par exemple
il ya vraiment cette notion de
pénibilité qui est mésestimé
et tant qu'on n'a pas réhabituer la
population à ce que c'est que la réalité
du travail agricole on n'avancera pas je
pense que ça reste donc les candidats
qu'ils étaient naïfs ont ces trois cent
mille personnes
elles sont inscrites elles restent
inscrits et ça permet de créer un lien
et moi j'ai parlé avec les gens de qui
ont créé ces plateformes là ils se
disent bon on a mal calibré au départ
effectivement il faut des gens formaient
un minimum donc à partir de là il
commence à leur envoyer des vidéos sur
qu'est ce que c'est que de cueillir des
abricots qu'est ce que ça implique que
de ramasser des fraises c'est fatigant
pour que les gens soient alertées nombre
d'heures dans la journée travaillée
également connaissance de cause parce
que l'idée c'est de recréer ce lien qui
sont un lien durable
les gens qui viennent de l'étranger sont
peu près 70 milles 1 chaque année en
saisonnier qui viennent de l'étranger y
reviennent tous les ans ces sont des
métiers qui connaissent ils savent pas
lisse et une vigne ils savent manier la
gauche et pour un agriculteur quelqu'un
qui vous écrasent vos fraises et
framboises ou chivu ravages vos asperges
c'est un vivier habitués et ça s'invente
pas
la parole à stéphane qui a très envie de
réagir et je vous la donne juste après
richard ramos
c'est vrai que la spontanéité n'est pas
forcément mais je l'entendais comprenait
un peu à la défense de du courage des
français renoncent abrité derrière des
difficultés techniques de savoir s'y
prendre
en temps normal chaque année il ya un
tiers des saisonniers qui viennent
travers l'agriculture qui vient de
l'étranger ça veut dire c'est un travail
que les français ne veut pas exactement
l'agriculture par exemple un
surveillance par un nettoyage essayant d
vraiment confrontés à ça on a une
population était à augmenter de niveau
de vie qui est plus à l'aise et si les
gens depuis la campagne s'est pas
produit retourné la résolution plutôt
réussis notamment des le champ personnes
à bord alors les français ne veut pas le
faire ne veulent pas te l'or est là
c'est parce qu'il regrette pas parce que
je pense que quand ils se sont inscrits
il ya un rapport à l'agriculture qui
étaient les gens aiment l'agriculture
nantis et les quelques mares il voulait
donner le coup de main c'est à dire la
volonté était là et donc ça c'est tout à
l'honneur des français
par contre que comme comme tout le monde
l'a dit c'est dur et aujourd'hui il faut
ce qu'il faut se mettre à la réalité sur
les emplois qui sont très dures eh bien
il ya peu de français qui veulent y
répondre elodie long cette difficulté à
recruter alors que la crise économique
arrive elle n'est pas liée à cet ancien
chaque année ses soixante dix mille
emplois non pourvus dans l'agriculture
10000 en cdi qui ne sont pas des petits
jobs qui sont des job correctement payés
ces femmes entrevue le monde d'après
beaucoup le voient avec un rapatriement
de l'agroalimentaire la souveraineté
alimentaire en france quand on voit ce
flop là on se dit mais il ya un décalage
immense sa part grèce ne pourra pas rhdp
plaie de paysans nos nos terroirs
non mais de toute façon il faudra
reproduire locale je dirais c'est une
évidence je veux dire même les français
qui ont été confinés ils se sont remis
avec des fruits à faire des tartes avec
leurs enfants
et donc ce goût-là du produit ce goût là
et cette réflexion qui a été celle du
confinement
elle doit permettre sans fouet pour la
cueillette c'est compliqué et on
trouvera des solutions dites par un gros
problème nommé il ya toujours des
problèmes mais on l'a dit est les
travailleurs détachés et bien faisons en
sorte que ces travailleurs détachés
on accepte de ne pas se cacher derrière
son petit doigt de se dire que
finalement ces gens là ça fait partie de
notre économie et qu'on est content de
les accepter quand ils viennent
travailler chez nous
ce qu'on a besoin d'eux mais comme c'est
des sujets tabous parce que ça rappelle
des sujets sur les migrants
l'immigration etc
c'est les sujets pour mai sous la table
et bien prenons les sujets sans les
mettre sous la table on a besoin d'une
indépendance alimentaire
vous savez que ça fait 20 ou 30 ans je
réclame sa et donc on a aujourd'hui
cette possibilité là parce que la
demande est là on a des français qui
sont presque prêt aujourd'hui à payer un
peu plus cher parce que ça serait
produit si mais encore une fois encore
une fois faut tout accompagné c'est pas
c'est pas si simple que ça
madame qui est journaliste au point et
vous dira qu'il ne vend pas il faut
aussi des moyens des gens et les moyens
d'acheter un peu plus cher et donc j'ai
c'est un tout et même à voir maintenant
à bras le corps dans des situations vous
n'aviez pas le sentiment que j verser un
petit peu la magie de des émotions des
consignes et stefan wey je me demandais
à vous demander monsieur marin monsieur
ramos qui n'avait pas l'impression que
le gouvernement tergiversait un petit
peu juste pour les raisons évoquées on
parle d'immigration
attention ne pas donner le sentiment
qu'on avait que l'immigration alors le 7
mai qu'à scanner dit c'est bon donne des
dérogations pour les travailleurs le
onze maires on arrête de 100
travailleurs espagnols à la frontière on
leur dit de rentrer chez eux le 13 mais
ni des lieux guy là on attend quand même
et dérogation vous croyez que c'est
parce qu on ne peut pas donner le
sentiment qu'en double parts à
l'immigration
oui audace est ce vous avez entièrement
raison mais il est en moi je les dis je
le répète je suis dans la majorité
présidentielle
jeudi on a été élu pour faire de la
politique autrement et bien c'est le
moment
faisons de la politique autrement et
acceptons la réalité qui est face à nous
parce que c'est l'objectif qui est le
plus important
l'objectif c'est la résilience
alimentaire territoriales vous dites que
ce soir il faut régulariser aucune des
travailleurs il faut et nous venger et
travailler sur le territoire on a besoin
et qu'on a on admet qu'on en a besoin il
faut lire il faut leur dire pas
forcément les régulariser mais leur dire
vous avez le droit de venir pour une
saison travailler chez nous moi je sais
c'est une partie de solutions
effectivement mais là ce que vous dites
vous et le droit de venir pour une
saison c'est ce qui existe déjà donc je
ne vois pas tellement le que ce que ça
change ce qui ce qui me semble
intéressant dans ses initiatives là
c'est aussi de ramener vers ce travail
de la terre des salariés qui demain vont
peut-être être en grande difficulté or
les îles sont aperçus les agriculteurs
qui les embauchent qu' il y avait des
liens qui se faisait très bien avec
notamment les travailleurs du de
l'hôtellerie tourisme
ce sont des gens qui sont habitués à des
travail pénible ils sont debout toute la
journée des nations unies dit fort
heureux clarisse
oui il ya des formes de reclassement
possible mais maintenant l'agriculture
souffre aussi d'une image qui est
déplorable
les gens n'ont pas non plus envie ils
s'imaginent que c'est extrêmement mal
payés ça ne l'est pas plus que dans
d'autres secteurs ça pourrait être
valorisé ça on s'entend bien et ils
s'immiscent est aussi c'est honteux
c'est c'est simplement dévalorisé mais
comme le sont beaucoup de métiers
manuels en france et c'était et c'est un
tort maintenant il faut on assure la
hausse effective de la dre j'aperçois on
a aussi cette immense hypocrisie en
france qui est que on un discours public
qui vous dit le local c'est formidable
le bio c'est l'avenir c'est
extraordinaire je vous rappelle que le
bio c'est 40 % de rendement en moins et
puis faut aller désherber à la main donc
moi j'attends qu'on m'explique dans les
politiques publiques qu'on met en oeuvre
qui va aller désherber les champs à la
main aujourd'hui on voit très bien qu'il
n'ya pas ses effectifs là ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il les aura pas demain mais il
ya un vrai travail de reconquête à faire
auprès de la jeunesse sont quand même
des métiers qualifiés maintenant on
l'est on les voit cueillir les fraises
quelqu'un decay des fraises le reste de
l'année il fait d'autres choses il faut
maîtriser la technologie les
agriculteurs aujourd'hui ils sont hyper
connectés ils ont des écrans des
capteurs qui leur disent comment ce sont
des outils qu'il faut maîtriser et il
faut former une jeunesse pour ça donc si
ces trois cent mille là ils ont envie je
trouve que c'est quand même c'est un
premier pas well un premier pas ils
connaissent pas ils ont envie mais il
faut se saisir de cette opportunité là
pourquoi y ait assez transition possible
oui je crois je crois à cette transition
possible parce que on voit bien qu'il ya
aussi une jeunesse qui étaient dans la
rue pour l'écologie et qui a envie de
participer même quand elle n'est pas
qualifiée à ce à ce nouveau monde mais
pas parce qu'il ya ulcos vide 19 noeuds
noeuds parce qu'il ya une volonté de
faire autrement et on a des gens qui
étaient qui sont qualifiés et qui vont
aller faire une saison là une haute
saison et qui vont qu'il opère pas
forcément être tout le temps sur le même
métier mais qui vont notamment retourné
à l'agriculture en fait c'est toujours
la question de l'opportunité du moment
on se dit rapatrions notre souveraineté
alimentaire sur notre sol ça veut dire
il faut s'asseoir sur les coups ça veut
dire qu'on va on va payer plus cher
notre alimentation elle sera peut-être
meilleur est-ce que c'est compatible
avec la crise économique en ce moment et
c'est la même question avec quel vendeur
si elle n'est pas fort mais si on se
rend compte que c'était très difficile
de voilà concrètement de réussir à faire
revenir les gens non mais ce travail là
on a le droit de courir toujours ya une
forme de parade un coup et mais il ya
des paradoxes mais si on court toujours
au prix le plus bas à la fin c'est les
plus pauvres qui trinquent
c'est les plus pauvres qui sont les plus
obèses c'est les plus obèses qui ont
requis qui chope le coc vide et derrière
on a un système qui est mortifère quand
je veux du prix bas je fous du sud dans
mon saucisson ça retient la flotte et je
fais croire aux pauvres que je le
revends de la viande au prix de l'eau et
donc ce système là c'est on fait d'abord
de la politique qu'est ce qu'on veut et
on détermine une politique dans les
vingt ans sur ce qu'on a envie on
détermine les nouvelles
non non on met par exemple on prend les
produits la concurrence des produits
entre les produits français et les
produits qui sont les produits apportés
vient d'europe dehors d'europe torah et
bien donc un produit qui n'a pas les
mêmes normes d'accord eh bien il faut
l'interdire c'est à dire et là moi je
vous le dis dans le monde d'après on est
en train de réfléchir à plusieurs sur
une tva notamment sur les produits
agricoles qui serait soit une trêve et à
très basses ou soit qu'ils seraient
proportionnels au kilomètre parcouru
c'est à dire redonner du sens à ce que
l'on fait géraldine et donc mais pardon
excusez moi ça demande du courage
politique
ça te dit ça veut dire d'abord de dire
je me donne tel objectif et je
convergent les moyens pour que tous les
moyens ensemble et là c'est là où ces
pardons nouveau moi vous m'avez vu
combattre la grande distribution
vous m'avez vu le combat de temps en
temps les industriels on m'a proposé de
signer plein de tribune que j'ai refusé
le temps il est à regarder tous en
commun de la fourchette à la fourche
c'est à dire du consommateur jusqu aux
paysans comment on peut faire en commun
quelque chose c'est à dire que il faut
pas ton leur part et je m'inclus dedans
dans des combats qu'ils soient des
combats qui divise le coville doit nous
avoir appris que peut-être on peut
essayer pas des partis politiques
différents
des métiers qui d'habitude s'oppose à
faire en commun ce qui est possible de
faire en commun j'entends parfaitement
mais je pense qu'il ya pas non plus de
solution magique et les grands plans qui
vous dit ça va être formidable
il n'y a qu'à faire ceci c'est un
domaine qui est extrêmement complexe
l'alimentaire ce mois ci qu'est un par
emmanuel macron comme l'un des grands
secteurs sur lesquels il faut reprendre
live des médicaments on ne sait pas la
balance commerciale agricole elle
s'effondre elle a été divisée par deux
en six ans et s'il avait pas les vins et
les spiritueux elle serait déjà
déficitaire donc nous on garde en france
et c'est heureux et c'est un modèle
qu'on chérit ce modèle de petites
exploitations familiales agricoles d'ici
trois ans il ya peut-être un peu plus
mais un tiers des exploitants ont plus
de 55 ans ils vont partir
qu'est-ce qu'on fait comment on fait
pour garder ce modèle de petites
exploitations familiales quand ce n'est
pas le modèle allemand quand ce n'est
pas le modèle des pays bas et ce sont
eux qui nous prennent les parts de
marché parce que ils arrivent à produire
sur les plus grandes surfaces pour moins
cher quoi voilà nous on a en plus une
sur 11 / norme c'est à dire que on est
scellée dans toutes les normes
européennes on les applique plus en
france antilles ailleurs maintenant vous
expliquer aux agriculteurs que tout va
bien se passer
il ne vous croient plus ils nous coûtent
très cher même vous aurez le mot de la
fin on ronge on sent bien qu'on vous
range du côté des optimistes un canton
monde d'après sur l'agriculture et
l'alimentation mais qu'est ce que vous
répondez aux objections ou remarques et
de géraldine
non c'est pas d objection puisqu'elle a
décrit deux mondes parallèles différent
celui d'une agriculture locale avec des
coûts qui seront plus chers et des gens
qui ont envie de manger français
c'est le deuxième critère après le prix
d'accord et une agriculture qui est sur
le commerce mondial et qui doit se
comparer aux autres qui ont des coûts
qui sont moindres que les notes avec des
normes qui sont pas les mêmes dont on
parle de deux parallèles qui sont pas
tout à fait les mêmes
moi je dis il faut d'abord défendre
l'alimentation sur les territoires et
faire en sorte que quand c'est un
circuit qui est court qu'on mange bien
on doit faire en sorte que notamment
dans ce qui va arriver sur la pac sur le
pilier 2 ont refoulé ch sur ses
politiques sur les politiques de
proximité
et puis aussi hélas madame a raison sur
les paysans qui exportent
faut aussi faire en sorte qu'on leur
mette pas des boulets aux pieds parce
que si on leur met des boulets aux pieds
ils seront pas compétitifs
merci beaucoup enfin s'arrêter là on
part de la cueillette avec voilà
quelques éléments pour la prêt même si
bon ça marche pas parce que c'est un
métier et on arrive avec richard ramos à
ce monde-là prêt ou l'alimentation
redeviendra au fond notre notre
souveraineté notre maître merci beaucoup
et à bientôt on va parler à présent des
prisons qui aurait pu imaginer qu'un
virus ait raison de la surpopulation
carcérale est bien pour la première fois
il ya moins de détenus derrière les
barreaux que de places en prison dans le
pays le taux de remplissage est de 98%
alors comment at on réussi ça comment
maintenir aussi ce nouvel équilibre
après l'épidémie avant d'accueillir nos
invités clément méric et clément
perreault sont allés tourner à la prison
de la santé
reportage exclusif pour lcp bilan de
deux mois d'enfermement dans
l'enfermement regarder à la santé les
parloirs ont rouvert hier mais tout a
été repensé pour faire barrage au virus
le détenu qui accèdent à la zone des
parloirs avant passé sous le portique de
détection
il ya un premier lavage des mains
obligatoire il nous remet une charte
aussi dans lequel ils s'engagent à
respecter les gestes barrières à ne pas
avoir de contact physique avec la
personne visitée
on leur rappelle que le port du masque
est obligatoire et ensuite donc ils vont
rentrer dans des cabines qu'on a
réaménagé
voyez donc la table elle fait 60 cm donc
on a rajouté 20 centimètres de chaque
côté
ici plus qu'ailleurs le déconfinement et
progressif car le milieu carcéral est un
terreau idéal pour le coronavirus salle
de sport bibliothèque ou salles de
classe restent donc fermé mais si le
pire a été évité
c'est avant tout parce que 250 détenus
en fin de peine ont été libérés bonjour
ça va ça va très bien on nous promettait
quand même l'apocalypse dans les prisons
le bilan chiffré ne dis pas ça en deux
mois à peine huit détenus ont été
contaminées le dispositif a donc été
efficace il a aussi permis aux agents
pénitentiaires de travailler
différemment
objectivement on a eu un accord sur les
conditions de travail un peu plus
tranquille comparé à l'habitude parce
que une suspension des activités qu'on a
beaucoup de passes entre la course et on
peut pas trop trop discute avec les
gones peut pas faire de nîmes un club
comme ça ça réduit le nombre de détenus
on peut vraiment faire son boulot à
coeur quoi vraiment s'il ya des
problèmes vraiment les gérer au cas par
cas mais dans les premiers jours
les détenus ont eu du mal à accepter ces
nouvelles restrictions
au début ça a été un petit peu compliqué
avec des petites tensions il ya eu il ya
eu des réunions toutes les semaines qui
nous ont beaucoup aidés on a été tenu au
courant de l'avancée du virus ici à la
santé le dialogue a aidé les libérations
également on est passé de 870 si je dis
pas de bêtises à 600 détenus ont parlé
que de ça en promenade sont très bonnes
nouvelles continuent après bien sûr que
oui
vous y croyez on y croit et tout le
monde tout le monde y croit ici ah bein
n'est pas le seul à vouloir y croire
le directeur de la santé aussi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui si on doit tenir des
leçons de cette crise sanitaire
c'est d'une part que vider les prisons
c'est possible parce qu'on l'a fait très
rapidement et s'est d'autre part qu'il
faut peut-être qu'on se pose maintenant
très sérieusement la question de comment
te punir autrement que d'entasser les
gens dans des dans des établissements
encouragé par la promesse d' emmanuel
macron le directeur de la santé veut
croire quand en prison aussi plus rien
ne sera comme avant
bonsoir stéphane breda merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous êtes le
directeur de l'administration
pénitentiaire
pour faire simple vous êtes le patron de
toutes les prisons françaises
on va évidemment revenir sur ce
reportage les conséquences qui sont
positives conséquences du coronavirus
sur la peau surpopulation carcérale
juste un mot s'il ya un endroit où il
faut un nom d'après c'est celui de la
prison oui sans doute
en tout cas il faut qu'on puisse
capitaliser construire sur les acquis
notamment de la crise sanitaire en tout
cas les effets qu'a eu la crise
sanitaire sur la surpopulation carcérale
et vous allez nous raconter exactement
ce qui s'est passé dans les prisons
pendant ces deux mois d'enfermement dans
l'enfermement
bonsoir maitena bonjour merci par
maïtena bien à bas bienvenue dans cette
émission dans ça vous regarde et surtout
bravo pour des confiné en est heureux où
on a du plaisir à la faire cette
émission c'est une belle émission deux
mois deux mois de débit d'eau vous
l'avez dit tant que les parloirs étaient
fermés on faisait cette émission qui
s'adressait donc à ce qu était dedans
donc les personnes détenues les
personnels pénitentiaires et puis en
même temps tous ceux qui expérimentait
bien même si être confiné dehors ça n'a
rien avoir à être avec enfermé en prison
bien entendu mais on pouvait se dire
qu'il y avait quelque chose qui nous
rapprochait les uns les autres et qui
nous permettait de penser à ce qui était
enfermée c'est la première émission et
télévisions qui s'adresse aux détenus au
personnel et les forains vendredi sur
lcp 19h30 ça donne ça regardez les
confiner parce que on fait une émission
sur les fringues ou pas du tout qui ne
s'est jamais laissé enchaîné ne saura
jamais ce qu'est la liberté
j'écoute les bruits de la ville je suis
battu contre la loi est la loi a gagné
ma liberté c'est toi qui m'a aidé à
larguer les amarres
cette émission s'adresse à toutes les
personnes détenues au personnel
pénitentiaire à tous ceux qui sont en
prison mais également à tous ceux qui
sont confinés dans leur appartement ou
dans leur maison j'avais encore il y en
a plus c'était la liberté dépend
on va là chaque semaine un directeur de
prison mais aussi des conseils de
lecture une grande voix qu'est ce que
vous avez appris sur sur ces gens-là ce
monde-là de la prison on a découvert
votre monde
monsieur on a découvert la pénitentiaire
on a découvert des directeurs de prison
et dès le premier truc qui me vient
c'est un des surveillants qui on a donné
la parole et on les entend rarement été
très heureux de porc s'exprimer qui nous
dit je lui demandais s'il faisait un
métier comme un autre
si on s'habituait à ce métier là et il
m'a répondu un peu comme ça me met mais
vous savez moi je garde des humains on
peut pas s'habituer à ça et c'est un
bizarrement et si j'ai l'air bisounours
tant pis ça n'est pas c'est une réalité
c'est un monde d'humanité en fait la
prison alors vous avez au cours de la
dernière est ce que c'est la dernière
peut-être pas mais on verra des missions
qui sera diffusé vendredi
vous avez pu interroger la ministre de
la justice nicole belloubet et vous
l'avez fait évidemment réagir à la
baisse spectaculaire du nombre de
détenus je rappelle qu'on est passé de
72 mille cinq cents à moins de 60 milles
le coc vide at il eu raison et bien de
cette surpopulation carcérale voilà sa
réponse
ce résultat la diminution de la
population carcérale
il est dû d'une part au fait que les
tribunaux au moins fonctionné puisque il
était au ralenti
donc ça effectivement c'est directement
le résultat de covile 19 mais d'un autre
côté nous avons pris des dispositions
pour de manière globale anticipé la
libération des détenus qui étaient en
fin de peine et cette politique
volontariste la a conduit au résultat
que vous connaissez mais c'est bien la
crise du candide qui nous y amène
absolument mais ma préoccupation c'est
de ne pas revenir au taux de
surpopulation carcérale que nous avions
atteint avant cette crise là
c'est vraiment pour moi une
préoccupation majeure stéphane breda
merci le coc vide d'une certaine manière
oui c'est vrai que par le passé on a
déjà eu des baisses spectaculaires la
population carcérale
après les grandes lois d'amnistié en 80
en 2002 la dernière les décrets grâce
présidentielle mais tout ça a disparu
depuis très longtemps depuis près de 20
ans est ce que nous enseigne l'histoire
c'est que c'est tout de suite très vite
remonter en fait une loi d amnistie un
décret de grâce ça fait baisser la
population carcérale et ensuite elle re
re et augmente au rythme d'avant très
bien bien comprendre pour ceux qui nous
regardent
il ya douze mille détenus ans - pourquoi
parce qu'il ya 6000 c'est bien ça qui
ont été libérés parce qu'ils étaient en
fin de peine
libération anticipée c'est anticiper et
6000 autres en fait qu'ils sont parents
pas rentrer et d'une certaine façon
puisque les les juridictions sont c'est
un peu plus compliqué que sa mère est
d'abord c'est 13500 tête nue en moins
maintenant si on actualise aux chiffres
réserve soit 13 500 c'est à dire qu'on
est passé de 72 mille cinq cents comme
vous le rappeliez on est quasiment à 59
milles mais ils sont tout à l'heure où
je parle on doit être en dessous de 59
milles ça veut dire qu'il ya des places
vides en prison aujourd'hui en france ça
veut dire qu'à des places vides dans les
prisons en france puisque on est à 98 %
97 % de taux d'occupation depuis le
début de la semaine mais ce chiffre il
cache encore et on le voyait à travers
les témoignages de certains détenus ou
même d'anciens détenus ils cachent
encore des fortes disparités se dire que
cette moyenne nationale à 97% ça veut
dire quand même encore dans l'est dans
les maisons d'arrêt c'est à dire les
maisons d'arrêt les établissements qui
existent dans chaque département ou où
sont notamment incarcérés les prévenus
qui sont présumés innocents beaucoup les
courtes peines et le taux d'occupation
il est encore à 110 % en moyenne
et cette moyenne elle cache des
disparités très fortes faut dire que la
surpopulation ça veut dire de manière
pratique ces lieux les coudes
ça veut dire deux voire trois personnes
dans une cellule de 9 mètres carrés si
on est content de cette si on n'a pas de
chance et ça veut dire donc qu'on dort
par terre sur un matelas donc ça veut
dire deux lits l'un au dessus de l'autre
et 1,10 par terre et rien d'autre il
faut tenir toute la journée parce qu'il
n'y a rien d'autre à faire puisque ap
une activité il ya plus de parloirs
donc c
et c'est chaud quand même c'est que
c'est costaud c'est un des effets
d'ailleurs les plus spectaculaires
puisqu'on a perdu 75% des matelas au sol
quand vous travaillez beaucoup mieux en
fait j'adore cette expression j'ai perdu
mon matelas au sol
pourvu que c'est à dire exactement oui
et d'ailleurs je crois qu'une partie des
personnels qui ont été interviewés dans
les différentes émissions le disait bien
ça change la manière de travailler on a
plus de temps on est moins dans la
gestion des flux en tout cas dans les
maisons d'arrêt qui comme par exemple en
ile de france ou en rhône alpes sont des
niveaux de suroccupation en temps normal
de 160 180 200 %
on est dans la gestion de flux longère
des détours de retour de parloir détour
de promenades et des tours de douche et
ça a été plus facile comme ça c'est
d'éviter d'éviter la contamination
possible exactement ça s'est bien passé
finalement ce qu'on peut dire en tout
cas pendant la première phase de la
crise sanitaire qui était somme toute
est le plus finalement l'épidémie allait
rester très contenue elle a même moins
touchées les détenus en détention que la
population générale finalement donc la
stratégie de protection sanitaire qu'on
a mis en place dans les prisons jusqu'à
dans cette première phase de la crise
elle a été elle a été efficace oui
comment on fait monsieur le directeur de
l'administration pénitentiaire comment
on fait pour qu'on reparte pas en avant
parce qu'il va y avoir de nouveaux
procès de nouvelle décision
d'incarcération
comment on fait pour se battre contre ça
alors il ya plusieurs choses
1 contrairement aux lois d'amnistié au
décret de grâce où l'activité
juridictionnelle était la même avant
comme après ici on a une activité
juridictionnelle qui va reprendre
progressivement
donc les lacs arsenal l'inflation
carcérale sans doute pas reprendre au
même rythme qu'avant la crise
deuxièmement il ya quand même cette
baisse spectaculaire la surpopulation
carcérale elles frappent tous les
esprits et et on en parle si j'ose dire
enfin et c'est une question qui s'impose
dans le débat politique même si elle a
beaucoup occupé par le monde dans les
trois dernières années lors du débat sur
la loi de programmation et puis
troisièmement c'est ce qu'espèrent tous
les praticiens de la justice c'est que
entre temps pendant la crise est entrée
en vigueur la réforme des peines le 24
mars dernier et donc l'activité des
juridictions l'activité des juridictions
pénales
elle va reprendre avec 1
trois différents est un droit qui pose
le principe que les courtes peines non
pas à s'exécuter en prison et c'est bien
ce qu'a montré cette crise c'est que on
pouvait fortement diminuer le nombre des
courtes peines puisque l'essentiel des
détenus qui sont sortis ce sont les
courtes peines alors justement on va
écouter un nouvel extrait de votre
interview maitena nicole belloubet vous
lui avez demandé et maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'on fait au moment où je vous parle
nous avons des dispositifs législatifs
qui je l'espère parce que il faut qu'ils
souhaitent utiliser par une magistrale
par les personnels pénitentiaires
nous avons un dispositif législatif qui
doit vous permettre de pallier cette
remontée de population carcérale qui va
forcément découler de la remise en
marche des tribunes donc c'est bien aux
tribunaux de décider d'appliquer
d'autres solutions plutôt que la prison
bien sûr d'une part c'est le tribunal
qui c'est le tribunal qui prononce la
peine et donc c'est évidemment très
important c'est le juge qui juge
d'application des peines
suit les peines donc c'est évidemment
les magistrats qui détiennent la clé de
ce double par dont elle est sans langue
de bois là elle est sans aucune aide
d'aucune manière dans la langue de bois
extrêmement détendu extrêmement clair
j'étais extrêmement heureuse de cette
interview ça faisait ça faisait du bien
d'entendre une miss je dis cela parce
que font ceux qui nous écoutent là sont
en train de se dire mais c'est quoi ces
des gauchistes échevelé qui veulent que
plus personne n'aille en prison n'ont
cessé et c'est aussi ça le grand
malentendu dans ce pays dès qu'on parle
de la prison on parle de gens qui ont
fauté et dont on pense qu'ils doivent
être punis bien entendu je ne suis pas
en train de dire que on vit au pays des
oiseaux s'est pas de l'été il faut
préciser tout de suite que parmi les
libérations
ça n'est que des fins de peine ou c'est
ça de moi c'était deux mois avant la
sortie voilà pour les actions de
terrorisme ou autre c'est très agréable
d'être la ministre parce qu'elle est
assez courageuse la dernière ministre
dernière garde des sceaux à avoir
accepté de porter une politique pénale
c'est absolument pas populaire de dire
qu'on ne veut pas engorger les prisons
on a l'impression qu'on dit qu'on ne
veut pas condamner les coupables c'est
pas du tout le sujet on veut condamner
les coupables mais mettre quelqu'un en
prison donc détruire sa vie lui il perd
son logement y perd son travail il perd
la rupture familiale parfois n'a aucun
sens si on peut faire autrement
si on peut punir en demandant réparation
à la société autrement qu'en excluant du
monde et en condamnant à l'indignité et
voilà c'est effectivement ce que à quoi
une société devrait s'astreindre mais
c'est vrai que ça nous touche à moi
honnêtement je m'étais pas du tout
intéressé aux prisons à part en lisant
quelques poètes de loin quoi voilà où en
garde en prison break mais la balle est
dans le camp des juges c'est ce que dit
la ministre en fait il ya déjà des
outils des moyens de trouver des peines
alternatives à la détention dans
certains cas précis
alors on n'a pas toute l'interview de la
ministre regardera la dernière émission
j'espère et je suppose que les miens
soir 19h30
je suppose que la garde des sceaux elle
évoque évidemment la responsabilité de
l'autorité judiciaire puisque à la fin
des fins la sentence pénale la peine de
prison elle est prononcée par des juges
mais elle est prononcée au terme d'un
procès au terme d'un procès pendant
lequel un avocat plaide une peine aussi
et pas simplement l'acquittement ou la
relaxe donc l'entrée en vigueur de cette
réforme pénale qu'on a porté depuis
trois ans elle est aussi la chose des
avocats qui doivent s'emparer des
nouvelles mesures qui doivent plaider
aussi les autres peines que la prison
pour les concours de ses toiles à le
dire le bracelet la semi liberté etc
donc il ya d'autres peines qui existent
en alternative crédible avec un vrai
contenu à la aux courtes peines de
prison il s'agit pas de dire qu'il faut
trouver des alternatives à
l'incarcération des criminels condamnés
à vingt ans et c'est pas ça le sujet est
ce que montre bien cette crise est que
il y avait suffisamment détenus en
condamnés à des courtes peines ou en fin
de peine pour que pour que c'est les
chiffres diminuent aussi fortement et
puis il ya un autre acteur que
l'émission a mis en valeur et je pense
que
le français moyen connaissent assez peu
sont les services pénitentiaires
d'insertion et de probation spip
ils servent à deux choses ils servent à
aider les magistrats à prononcer la
peine la plus adaptée au profil et à
l'acte commis par le prévenu
et ils servent ensuite pendant toute la
durée de la peine à donner du sens à la
peine à donner du contenu à 7 les
tribunaux ont repris on reprenne
progressivement
est-ce qu'on a une tendance sur les noms
des incarcérations cette renault pas
assez de recul pour pour le dire les
tribunaux en tout cas dans la justice
pénale devons prioriser certaines
affaires notamment les assises c'est pas
les assises qui pourvoit le plus le plus
grand nombre de deux détenus et puis le
vrai curseur ce avec la reprise des
comparutions immédiates
tiens un petit chiffre si vous parce que
c'est très important ce que vous venez
de dire on a toujours l'impression qu'on
parle de gens très très dangereux
évidemment les gens qui passent en
procès d'assises donc qui ont tué
quelqu'un etc
c'est très peu de gens il ya 30 % des
détenus qui sont là pour plus de 15 ans
tous les autres ça veut dire 70% noms
sont là pour un deux ou trois ans
dépassant 10% d'aidé relativement
content quand vous les nouvelles
pardonnez moi allez vous donner une idée
la durée moyenne d'incarcération en
france ces dix mois et demi d'accord
c'est pas qu'un peu est ce qu'on sait
c'est ces détenus qui ont bénéficié de
libérations anticipées qui était en fin
de peine ce qu'ils sont devenus parce
que arriver dans une france confiné
partant de covin c'est quand même très
particulier
alors les mesures qui ont permis ces
libérations anticipées qui explique oui
à peu près un tiers la moitié de la
baisse de la population pénale
c'était d assignation à domicile
prononcées par le parquet ou l'octroi de
réduction de peine exceptionnelle dans
la limite des deux mois comme cela a été
rappelé tout à l'heure donc en fait ces
détenus ils sont sortis dans la france
confiné ils ont été confinés chez eux
donc c'est pour ça que ces dispositifs
l'effet est spectaculaire mais ça peut
pas des dispositif pérenne parce que ce
que je viens de vous dire tout à l'heure
c'est que le but c'est de de construire
des alternatives crédibles aux courtes
peines avec un contenu une peine de deux
mois
confiné chez soi avec une intervention
minimale du spi puisque les spip eux
mêmes étaient confinés donc c'est pas ça
le modèle pour construire vous disiez
tout à l'heure la prison d'après en tout
cas les peines d'après si on veut du
contenu du suivi de l'accompagnement ce
c'est pas simplement sortir sans dans
une france confiné donc ça c'était la
situation si j'ose dire transitoire est
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut contribuer à
construire cccc peine avec du contenu
n'a été menacé une émission qui
s'intitule lire pour en sortir des
confiné lire pour s'en sortir
quel est votre conseil de lecture fait
cas des détenus ou des surveillants qui
nous regardent ce soir à leur
destination
ben moi mon livre de chevet on l'enverra
alors c'est à dire qu'elle sait pellan
verra aussi en gage qu'on l'a fait non
parce qu'il faut quand même le dire
chaque semaine on a envoyé dans les
prisons dont on parlait les livres qui
ont été citées par tous nos invités y
compris par les députés moi je dirais
l'écriture où la vie de genre semprun
quand on revient de très loin et que on
sait que ce très loin il reste à
l'intérieur de nous-mêmes comment pas
s'en débarrasser parce qu'on s'en
débarrasse pas mais comment vivre avec
malgré moi c'est un livre pour moi si je
continue à en parler je me met à pleurer
donc c'est pas utile et chaleureux d'un
au moins mon livre de chevet suis pas
sûr qu'il soit extrêmement utiles aux
détenus parce que j'aurai volonté par
les deux mémoires d'hadrien en revanche
pour le haut fonctionnaire que je suis
il ya une forme d'éthique tu alors
j'exerce pas le pouvoir je suis au
fonctionnaire je pas ministre ni
parlementaire mais il ya une forme
d'éthique de l'engagement
l'engagement politique et de l'exercice
du pouvoir en tout cas l'exercice de
l'état essayé c'est ça qui me viendrait
comme lecture spontanément parce que
dans une dans un moment comme celui là
où il ya des circonstances
exceptionnelles il va falloir s'en
saisir et va falloir être à la hauteur
de ces circonstances exceptionnelles
pour pas simplement recommencer comme
avant
on sera au rendez vous pour vérifier
merci merci beaucoup merci stéphane
breda maïtena demain soir 19 heures où
ils ont été confinés
quelque chose me dit que c'est pas
forcément la dernière j'espère venir ou
valve ça c'est la dernière avec toutes
les interviews et puis on va se
retrouver encore la semaine prochaine
pour les meilleurs moments et y en a eu
tellement
mais tellement on allait le rendez vous
est pris merci à vous 24 heures à
l'assemblée maintenant c'est l'heure de
retrouver le carnet tour de thomas des
prêts thomas thomas il est ou mec mais
qu'est-ce qui fait thomas ce soir à vous
êtes là meriam aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler d'une histoire de plagiat supposé
c'est ma journée à l'assemblée à la
droite maximino députés les républicains
de l'oise
à ma gauche christophe blanchet député
la république en marche du calvados
entre eux le problème c'est ça un
ministre
nous en avons adressé il ya trois
semaines avec 100 députés de la majorité
une proposition offrir la possibilité
pour les salariés qui le veulent dans le
public comme dans le privé de faire don
d'une partie de leurs congés payés ou
rtt au bénéfice de ceux qui luttent
directement contre le coc vide 19 le
problème c'est que cette proposition
faite dans l'hémicycle mardi par
christophe blanche et aurait été faite
il y a deux mois par maximino alors qui
a eu l'idée en premier
on leur a posé la question bonjour
maximino bonjour alors comme ça vous
vous êtes fait voler votre idée
effectivement c'est une idée une
proposition de loi que j'ai fait en tout
cas à l'ensemble de mes collègues
parlementaires de l'assemblée nationale
le 22 mars dernier dans un esprit
effectivement d'unité nationale de
solidarité
mais quand j'ai découvert effectivement
au lundi qu'ils avaient repris à mon
idée à l'identique effectivement c'est
assez révoltant est assez rageant
bonjour christoph locher
maxime hulot dit que vous avez plagié
son idée comment vous réagissez
j'ai relu attentivement sa proposition
qui était très intéressante et très
intéressante parce qu'elle elle posa
proposition de permettre à des salariés
de lui comme du privé de donner leurs
congés payés vers une autre structure
plus vite qu'au privé en congés payés
c'est très intéressant notre proposition
c'est pas du tout ça c'est de
transformer le don de congés payés
volontaire ou de rtt en chèques vacances
pour les personnels soignants
alors même si la proposition est plutôt
différente pour christophe blanchet
maximino lui continue de crier au
copier-coller
c'est pas une bonne chose que la
majorité porte le texte maximino bien
sûr mais ça ça enfin moi je en tout cas
de mon côté je n'aurais aucun scrupule à
voter la loi qu'ils vont proposer si
effectivement je n'ai pas la possibilité
de dépôt de débattre de la met en avant
je suis pas dans le sectarisme
depuis mon arrivée au palais bourbon
j'ai fait les calculs du coup depuis
depuis cet épisode j'ai voté plus de 40%
des textes qui ont été proposées par la
majorité cas aujourd'hui je regrette
juste qu'il ne tombe pas la main à
l'opposition à leur tour qu'ils prônent
partout de l'unité nationale et l'union
nationale ça vient aussi dans le débat
politique
alors pour être tout à fait complet
cette proposition de faire don de ses
jours de congé aux soignants plaît
beaucoup à murray le pénicaud la
ministre du travail a dit qu'elle allait
y réfléchir et nous on se retrouvera
mardi pour une nouvelle journée à
l'assemblée myriam absolument thomas le
rendez vous est pris bonsoir camille ça
fait bien plaisir de trouver camille
saféris comment s'est déroulé ce moment
vous allez détruire
bon alors on se retrouve un bouquet à
pardonnez moi je demanderais à
l'habitude alesi de nos normes sert
qu'un petit décalage alors de l'apéro
évidemment prendre l'apéro parce que moi
c'est ce que je fais dans l'émission
allait prendre l'apéro avec des députés
maintenant c'est complètement ringard
désolé maintenant il faut prendre des
apéros vision donc moi j'ai bu l'apéro
en vidéo depuis chez moi avec ce soir
sylvain maillard sylvain maillard il est
député en marche ou paris et
figurez-vous qu'il n'est pas venu les
mains vides pour l'apéro il avait
apporté une bonne bouteille mais pas
n'importe laquelle une bouteille très
spécial regardez ce point là c'est un
vin qu'il faut pas avoir du tout du tout
du tout du tout d'accord c'est une cuvée
en fait des pompiers du 9e
arrondissement de paris avec des vignes
qui pousse sur la caserne blanc donc en
plein milieu de paris de l'extraire du
vin farine c'est une tradition depuis
des années des années et ils font une
bande anges avec des bouteilles que l'on
achète pour les bonnes oeuvres pourquoi
il faut pas de voir du tout alors à il
est il est invivable
ce n'est vraiment invivable personne ne
boit mais ça lui est très fier de
l'avoir connue
c'est un symbole on est très attentif à
ce qui se vend là parce qu'en fait il
est vendu dans une fête qui permet donc
de lever la retrouver l'argent pour les
les conflits ou les soldats blessés et
donc c'est un vin qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur
qu'est-ce qui a marqué dessus château
blanche et surtout ne buvait pas
décapant que l'apéro willems
moi j'aime bien ça le faire comme on dit
à ces apéros zoom on rompt alors on
retrouve à deux pattes
vous avez vu que comme beaucoup de
français comme richard ramos tout à
l'heure d'ailleurs si la manière il a
pris un peu de poids pendant le
confinement un malheureusement ça ça ça
se voit ainsi mal je vais donc me posez
la question franchement qu'est ce qui
s'est passé sylvain qui est responsable
pau ce carnage vous avez quoi quand vous
faites aller de 100 à 200 par an
nettement à beaucoup plus quand vous
passez la journée le week-end à la
maison
mangez vous grignotez c'est comme ça que
ça fasse je crois que j'ai entendu alors
je sais pas si tu aimerais vous mettez
deux kilos et demi en moyenne c'est vrai
depuis le début de confinement va être
vraiment un bref qu'est ce que vous avez
mangé pendant le confinement et ben on a
fait beaucoup de blanquette de veau
très très bien qu'ils aient beaucoup de
fruits de mer donc le responsable de
votre léger surpoids on peut dire ça
c'est vrai que vous avez un peu un tout
petit peu forcé depuis je vous ai vu
c'est une vraie caméra ou la caméra ce
c'est vrai que c'est sûrement la caméra
et c'est visiblement la blanquette quoi
principalement en tout cas alors à
l'assemblée
il ya désormais des règles sanitaires
très strictes masque j'ai les bras
et puis il t'a - monde il ya cinq
seulement 150 députés
vous le savez donc il ya aussi moins de
bruit et celle ci coûte mieux ce qui est
plutôt pas mal ou le dialogue politique
et finalement d'après sylvain maya les
bains c'est une bonne nouvelle ça a
construit aussi beaucoup plus de respect
les uns envers les autres
le respect qui existait en fait en
dehors de lui si ça va être des échanges
plus apaisée où on va davantage écouter
les idées des autres
3les devrais je pense que ce sera moins
polémique
on veut dire vous fait mal moi je serai
bien et vous fait mal la situation du
gouvernement elle est extrêmement
difficile et n'importe à la place
seraient confrontés aux mêmes
difficultés au même choix compliqués on
pourrait donc enfin s'entendre entre
opposants politiques
grâce aux masques et la distanciation ça
s'est fait en tout cas c'est le cas à
l'heure actuelle la bavure est mon avis
non en tout cas c'est très agréable
à l'heure actuelle doit le dire parce
que du coup chacun écoute beaucoup plus
les autres et chacun argumentation est
beaucoup plus court suite que d'habitude
mais c'est beaucoup plus valeur et ben
voila merci camille moi je trouve ça
marche bien vous apéro somme ça a fait
beaucoup rire l'histoire de blanc il a
été commandé votre blanquette hmam
l'enquêté bonne
merci oui on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine on termine avec le jour
d'après chaque soir vous savez un grand
entretien autour d'un thème au coeur de
cette épidémie
ce soir la géopolitique etats unis chine
europe qui va gouverner le monde de
l'après crise c'est sylvie kauffmann
journaliste au quotidien le monde qui
répond à nos questions
[Musique]
voilà pas mal ça va je peux m ou plus
loin comme ça bonjour sylvie kauffmann
jo et merci de nous accorder cet
entretien alors cette épidémie de
coronavirus elle bouleverse évidemment
tout sur son passage y compris la
géopolitique etats unis chine europe
on va en parler dans le détail mais
d'abord est-ce que vous avez été
surprise de voir qu'on n'a pas pu
répondre au niveau mondial à cette crise
ni au niveau du g20 et du g7
ni au niveau des nations unies c'est une
surprise ou pas pas vraiment parce que
ce qu'on peut dire de 7,2 de la
géopolitique de cette crise ou des
conséquences géopolitiques de cette
crise dans un premier temps c'est que
elle elle a accéléré cette crise a
vraiment accélérer de manière très
brutale est assez choquante mais des
tendances qui était déjà à l'oeuvre dans
dans l'ordre international mondial s'il
voulait on voyait bien déjà avant la
crise que cet ordre international qui
est hérité de la deuxième guerre
mondiale en fait qui l'ordre organisé
par les états unis
au 20ème siècle était déjà très mal en
point que la mondialisation était
critiquée que l'onu avait énormément de
mal à fonctionner que le conseil de
sécurité étaient bloqués sur la syrie de
manière permanente que le g7 ne marchait
pas très bien en plus le g20 faisait à
peu près son effet mais que l'om c était
aussi un peu en panne voilà on avait
déjà un phénomène qui était très visible
et qu'on analyse et beaucoup de noms pas
de désagrégation mais de détérioration
très nettes de l'ordre international
autre nouveauté avec cette crise c'est
qu'elle a été gérée pour partie par des
pouvoirs populiste donald trump jaillir
bol sonar au poutine or ban alors
pouvoir autoritaire aussi est ce que ça
change quelque chose dans la possibilité
d'une réponse coordonnée monde
de toute façon il y avoir un moment où
politiquement il va falloir rendre des
comptes et on va établir une sorte de
tableau de kia qui a réussi quel régime
a bien fonctionné quel régime on a mal
fonctionné on voit que la sinne se
targue d'avoir bien gérer sa crise
puisque le nombre de morts en chine est
bien bien bien inférieur au nombre de
morts aux etats-unis ou en europe en
réalité on ne sait pas si la chine a
vraiment bien gérer sa crise d'abord
parce qu'on ne sait pas si les chiffres
qu'elle lui fournit sont exactes et
ensuite il ya quand même ses doutes
énorme sur l'origine de l'épidémie qui
est parti de chine
on ne sait pas ce qui s'est passé dans
ses laboratoires de haut rhin donc là
pour l'instant il ya une opacité qui est
qui est une caractéristique des régimes
autoritaires mais qui nous empêche de
voir vraiment ce qui s'est passé la
grande surprise c'est la faiblesse de la
première puissance mondiale
donald trump s'est révélé incapable de
gérer de façon efficace cette crise il a
pris des mauvaises décisions
il avait coupé les crédits de la
recherche il a il a même remis en cause
le bureau d épidémie avant la crise et
voilà que tous les emplois créés avant
la crise ont détruit plus de 20 millions
de chômeurs en une semaine c'est ça au
fond de bilan de trump c'est une grande
faiblesse voire un désastre alors il y à
il ya deux choses
il y a le modèle américain et il y à la
gestion par son parent le président
donald trump
alors la gestion para par donald trump
vous venez de la décrire elle est
effectivement assez catastrophique en
tout cas vu vu d'europe
au début il a commencé par minimiser la
maladie il a dit que c'était une grippe
il a dit que ça serait terminée très
rapidement qui auraient zéro mort il a
été obligé de changer de stratégie
ensuite il s'est disputé avec les
gouverneurs notamment celui de new york
celui de californie et ceux dont les
états et elle est plus tout
et je ne parle pas des épisodes où le
président a même suggéré qu'on pouvait
s'injecter du désinfectant ainsi puisque
ça marchait pour pour nettoyer les
surfaces
voilà donc on a en effet une un
président en actions qui pose énormément
de problèmes avec des conséquences assez
lourdes pour son pays
et puis on a un modèle américain qui en
effet révèle ses faiblesses et pas la
première fois on l'a vu déjà pendant la
crise financière de 2008 c'est-à-dire
que dès que l'économie accuse un gros
choc
on a immédiatement des millions de
chômeurs des gens qui sont licenciés du
jour au lendemain qui ont beaucoup moins
de protection et d'indemnisation que
nous l'avons en europe
il n'y a pas de filet de sécurité
sociale à proprement parler aux
etats-unis est-ce que pour revenir à la
géopolitique les états unis et donald
trump doivent se donner un nouvel ennemi
alors peut-être qu'il l'était déjà mais
là il ya une mise en scène de l'ennemi à
travers la chine
donald trump décide de parler du virus
chinois de marteler cette expression
pour aussi retrouver une certaine forme
de puissance face à la vulnérabilité du
modèle américain
vous voyez bien sûr il ya cette il y à 7
cette idée d'attaquer la chine pour
trouver un peu pour essayer de comme
dérivatif d'une certaine manière pour
masquer ses propres erreurs de gestion
mais comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure
cette crise accélère les tendances déjà
à l'oeuvre sur le plan international et
la rivalité la compétition et
l'affrontement sino-américain entre la
chine et les états unis était déjà une
réalité du monde pré crise donc là on
voit cette cette compétition s'exacerber
avec la montée en puissance de la chine
qui essayent de manière très
spectaculaire et très visible de se
servir de cette crise pour montrer que
son modèle est le plus efficace et le
meilleur et vous montrer cette vidéo
regardée et malheureuse
one thing américaine conseil provincial
et le china state of the world
ça veut dire quoi ça c'est complètement
nouveau
alors c'est pas complètement nouveau
mais c'est beaucoup plus spectaculaire
est beaucoup plus accentuée que ce que
ce que ce qu'on avait vu avant
on voit que la chine veut faire de cette
crise une opportunité
ce qui est amusant parce que le mot
crise en chinois veut aussi dire
opportunité donc là on est vraiment dans
la dans la logique chinoise une certaine
manière et montrer que la chine a un
modèle supérieur à celui des etats unis
et comme les états unis sous la conduite
de donald trump sont en retrait sur le
plan international on voit bien là là
vraiment lieu dans cette crise les
etats-unis ont abandonné toute
prétention au leadership mondial
il ne s'en occupe même plus ils ont
tourné le dos aux alliés européens dès
le début de la crise en fermant les
frontières sans même les alerter ils ont
suspendu leur financement à l'om est
l'organisation mondiale de la santé qui
logiquement devrait être l'organisation
internationale la plus importante en ce
moment pour la communauté mondiale
donc on est vraiment là dans une
compétition féroce de ces deux modèles
et la chine
essaye d'en tirer le meilleur parti
alors face à ces deux géants etats unis
chine il ya l'europe il ya l'europe qui
peine à trouver sa place sur le plan
géopolitique est ce qu'on peut dire
qu'elle est pour l'heure la grande
perdante dans cette crise
vous avez tout à fait raison l'essence
même du projet européen est mise en
cause par cette crise c'est à dire en
effet vous avez deux piliers deux des
principaux piliers sur lesquels repose
l'union européenne qui ont été attaqués
le marché unique et l'espace schengen le
marché unique parce qu'on a vu des pays
et pas des moindres la france
l'allemagne
émettre dès le début de la crise des
interdictions d'exportation de matériel
médical au sein de l'union européenne
et puis l'espace schengen comme vous
l'avait dit il ya plus d'une douzaine de
pays qui ont fermé qui ont fermé leurs
frontières à un moment ou un autre pas
la france d'ailleurs il faut le
remarquer mais l'allemagne par exemple
le 15 mars a fermé ses frontières avec
cinq pays dont la france
il y avait une frontière en alsace pour
la première fois depuis très longtemps
dernière quête qui ont très rapidement
et pour vous mouiller un peu à quoi il
ressemblera cet ordre mondial après les
pays qui ont le mieux géré cette crise
vont gagner en influence en gagner en
soft pas aux avants gagner en images et
je crois que quand on parle on parlait
déjà beaucoup avant de la compétition
entre régimes autoritaires et démocratie
libérale
on voyait que les démocraties libérales
était à la peine d'une certaine manière
parce qu'on assistait à cette montée du
populisme et des et du nationalisme et
et d'autoritarisme et des leaders forts
mais finalement je crois qu'on voit que
les leaders forts ne se sont pas mieux
débrouillé que les démocraties libérales
au régime sont différents et finalement
ils ont ils montrent une résilience qui
relève du du consensus merci sylvie
kauffmann pour ce tour d'horizon
géopolitique d'aujourd'hui et de demain
au revoir et ainsi s'achève cette
émission se retrouvent mardi prochain
pour une nouvelle semaine de ça vous
regarde
elle défie la très belle soirée c'est
vrai je sais pas
[Musique]